you know there are two sides to the
personal finance equation there's the
income side and the outgo side we spend
a lot of our time on the show talking
about the outgo side and talking about
getting out of debt and living on a plan
and going to every dollar calm and
getting your budget set up and we spend
a lot of time on that
do you ever spend much time thinking
about where your income comes from
everything about why you make an income
why you make the income you make i rabbi
Daniel lapin wrote a wonderful book
called thou shall prosper it's such a
wonderful book that I agreed to write
the foreword to it when it was reissued
he spoke last week with our leadership
summit in San Diego and one of the
things he reminded me of it I've heard
him say this before but he reminded me
that your income is in direct proportion
over the long haul not on the short
range but over the long haul your income
is in direct proportion to this service
that you render people and people
together called society and and it's you
know admittedly it's what people are
willing to pay for in other words some
people say well I can't believe you know
a teacher they render a better service
to society than than a football player
and yet a football player makes millions
and a teacher doesn't I'm not talking
about the philosophical service I'm
talking about what the service that
people are willing to pay for and you
exist within that fixed universe that
fixed universe being other people are
making marketplace decisions it's Peyton
Manning a better person than your fourth
grade teacher no is he inherently as a
human being worth more than she is no
but more people are willing to pay to
see him do what he does than they are
your fourth grade teacher that's the
fact jack whether you agree with it or
not philosophically doesn't really
matter
and so whether you like Bill Gates or
not he's helped a whole lot of people
billions and made billions doing it by
the way but our world is completely
changed because of Bill Gates you really
can't argue that the personal computer
outlook Explorer windows changed our
world it really did now you can argue
maybe you don't like him personally
maybe you don't like this or that maybe
you don't like maybe you're an Apple
person you're not a Microsoft person
maybe you don't believe this or that you
heard he did something nasty or mean or
you don't agree with this pricing
structure you can argue about all of
that but at the other day doesn't matter
doesn't matter the reason Bill Gates is
one of the wealthiest people on the
planet is he's helped the most people on
the planet of anybody walking around he
helped more people than mother Teresa
did because he literally has caused
billions of people to have a different
life literally billions of people have a
different life because of him mother
Teresa is wonderful obviously she's the
saint obviously we can all aspire to
being more like her and Rabbi talked
about this last week and it's kind of
shocking when you mean you put Bill
Gates and Mother Teresa in the same
sentence it kind of makes you go say
what but what I'm talking about is
economic facts because our economy is a
capitalistic economy and people that
serve more people
make more money now sometimes they serve
them in ways we don't agree with I'll
give you an example online pornography
generates more revenue than all
professional sports put together in
America including NASCAR now obviously I
think that's trash filth nastiness
maybe not obviously but now that I've
said it it's obvious
it's obvious to me and it tears down
families and it messes up marriages and
it screws up men's brains and takes
advantage of women and degrades women
turns them into objects because you can
do a whole deal on online pornography
and how horrible it is and it is all of
those things but at the end of the day
enough people are willing to pay for it
for whatever sick reasons that it
generates more money than online sports
so it's not necessarily that it's a good
thing and not necessarily that it's a
thing you agree with but at the end the
day it's things people are willing to
pay for they're willing to pay a
computer programmer these days as much
as some doctors make these days and so
you know what people will fork over
money for and what they consider
themselves being served in that they're
willing to pay a thousand dollars for
one bottle of wine and won't pay ten
dollars for another bottle well it all
tastes the same to me well you wouldn't
be one of the willing ones willing to
pay for that then but somebody is
because they're selling them for a
thousand and so that is the world in
which you live whether you
philosophically agree with it or not
Tuffy's the income that you make is in
direct proportion to the number of
people that you serve in some way and if
you had scale to it you'll make more
money very simplistic thing and I think
it's a good thing obviously and I hope
you do when I sold 10 financial piece
books I helped 10 people and I made $1
apiece on them maybe maybe more maybe
less but something like that I made 10
bucks right but after I sold 5 million
of them
I made a buck apiece and made 5 million
dollars but 5 many people got helped so
I should have gotten paid more and so
it's kind of disturbing and it's it's
it's and I really want to help some of
you that are out there or at least
friends of some of you that you think
you have a right to make money because
you always got a trophy when you played
sports growing up
you're not entitled to anything
everybody gets a trophy is destroying
this generations perception of creating
value you have to go into the
marketplace and create value that
someone wants the marketplace is having
a conversation with you and so if you
have minimal skills and minimal
character you're going to make minimum
wage oh well I can deal with that you're
probably not even worth that you want to
make more money may get more skills you
want to make more money find a way to
serve and help more people and do it
with more scale that's where money comes
from that's where your income comes from
you do not deserve anything
you don't deserve squat
I don't deserve squat I'm going to get
what I earn and so are you I don't care
if you march in the street or not it
didn't going to matter
you're still going to get paid what the
marketplace will pay you for what you do
maybe you need to rethink that this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you